Ab sofort kann sich jeder seinen eigenen roboter bauen alles was man dazu braucht es
Einen 3d drucker und die gibt es ja inzwischen schon für übersichtliches geld und etwas geschick
Und zwar wirklich nicht viel beim roboter in mode sind die baupläne als open hardware offen für alle
Was wirklich hinter diesem projekt steckt was der roboter alles kann. Und noch weitere spannende infos mehr jetzt bei klicks, um, science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ein thema aus der klicks und community auf whatsapp. Und in anderen ländern
Vielen dank. Dafür wie er dahin kommt dass er vater am ende des videos es ist wirklich verrückt was manchmal
Und vor allem. Wo und wie
Technologiesprünge stattfinden wer hätte gedacht dass amerikas autoindustrie durch den. Bau von elektroautos
von tesla wiederbelebt wird aber der roboter in hof der ist faszinierend, und unheimlich zugleich
Er ist so groß. Wie ein mensch. Und hat genau. Wie wir zwar nur die beine fehlen aber
Dafür hat der augen in den kameras die objekte. Und menschen verfolgen können. Und auch. Gesten erkennt der roboter
Und zwar durch eine kinect in seinem bus kommt alles mit ganz einfachen mitteln
Und man kann sich auch mit ihm unterhalten spricht man. In anderen nennt ihm zahlen macht er die entsprechende programmierte g stone bestätigt. Dann beispielsweise
news.at land noch relativ simpel aber immerhin möglich machen das die spracherkennung lautsprecher
Und mikrofone mit denen in move ausgestattet ist aber jetzt. Noch mal von vorne entwickelt
Wurde der roboter von dem französischen bildhauer also einem bildhauer niek einem fachmann
Delonge war der ursprünglich eigentlich nur eine handprothese entwerfen. Wollte mit seinem, einen 3d drucker
Stellte er die hand her. Und fand dann aber. Kein ende, er wollte sein projekt mit anderen leuten teilen
und veröffentlichte die konstruktions dateien für seinen roboter auf
singles einer plattform für open source hardware
Die reaktionen waren überwältigend und logen war machte weiter, er nutzte. Einen microcontroller bord mit dem
Sich die finger mit hilfe von motoren kontrollieren lassen, und so ging es weiter mit schultern bizeps
Und so weiter bis in mustern so weit fertig war oberkörper. Kopf arme hände nur die beine
Fehlen wie gesagt. Dafür können aber die arme von jedem
Pc aus angesteuert werden insgesamt hat der roboter mittlerweile
26 servomotor die seine bewegungen steuern ansonsten läuft über eine 6 volt batterie ja sein erfinder hatte kurioserweise
Keine, ahnung er war ja bildhauer von elektronik oder robotertechnik dazu londoner selbst ich musste mich mit allen möglichen
anforderungen auseinandersetzen aber die elektronik habe ich immer vernachlässigt
Weil das nicht meine starke war ich war wirklich von der elektronik eingeschüchtert da ich nichts über sie wusste
Ja den, einen innenhof den gibt es übrigens nicht denn das ist ja die idee von open source jeder kann
Sich seine eigene roboter version basteln alle quellcodes. Konstruktions vorlagen
Und pro design prozesse werden offengelegt lounge war hat nur eine sache bezüglich imhof, geregelt er darf nicht
Kommerziell genutzt werden dafür fehlt die lizenz privat aber kann jeder der. Einen 3d drucker hat den roboter nachbau notwendig
Dafür ist, ein 12 x 12 x 12 cm großer baum die ganze wasser seien kostenlos wenn
Dann, etwa 1000 euro zehn bis hundertmal weniger als andere. Roboter dieser art dazu. Kommen natürlich. Noch die. Kosten für 3d drucker
und gelb ist
Wichtig dass die sache weiterhin als open source. Projekt läuft ich weiß zwar nicht ob roboter die von uns, erschaffen werden unser
Leben kraft verbessern werden aber sie werden uns in irgendeiner art und weise erweitern wie werkzeuge eben ich glaube
Daran dass roboter saß sein werden was wir menschen wollen und nicht
Mehr ja da gibt es ja auch verschiedene meinungen wir haben, darüber berichtet dafür soll in move demnächst auch
noch, beine bekommen und das wird sein gewicht von derzeit 17 kilogramm normal hin
Möchte. Ihm langfristig auch das laufen ermöglichen und es geht noch weiter
Forschungsteams weltweit tüfteln ja daran die beziehungen zwischen robotern. Und menschen zu verbessern. Und da helfen solche open source projekt natürlich
Auch das sind alles riesige schritte man darf das nicht unterschätzen
Wenn die hürden so niedrig gesetzt werden. Um, sich selber. Ein roboter bauen zu können das ist schon der wahnsinn
Ja und die forschungsteams die arbeiten beispielsweise. Dann an
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen, und
charaktereigenschaften
Die den robotern verliehen werden sollen sie sollen dann in der lage sein. Beziehungen zwischen menschen
Zu verstehen was es wiederum möglich machen würde dass die. Roboter selbst eine beziehung. Zu menschen aufbauen können. Also das sind schon
Gespenstische perspektiven ja aber heute fehlen den. Robotern noch diese menschlichen charakteristika wenn
Ihr kein video zur entwicklung von robotern zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich beim wort app. Und in anderen messengern nur
Dann, verpasst er kein video denn die abo box auf youtube das wisst. Ihr ja dieses ziemlich rücken
Und über die messenger da erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Einfach hier draufklicken
Und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks, um, social media abonnieren das geht hier dann erfahrt
Ihr das neueste aus der social media welt aber nicht wenn, er hier drauf klickt die
Genau, glocke vergessen und c hier geht es weiter. Dafür auch. Darauf blicken roboter sofia will menschheit zerstören
bis dann
bleibt dran